un pour tous pour un cette devise vous
dit sûrement quelque chose c'est celle
des Trois mousquetaires d'Alexandre
Dumas mais ces personnages ont-ils
vraiment existé d'Artagnan d'où sort-il
Thibault de la chaîne Histoire appliquée
à enfiler sa cape et son chapeau et vous
allez le voir ça ne manque pas de
panache
bonjour Jamy et bonjour à tous quand on
pense aux Trois Mousquetaires on imagine
généralement de grands-gaillards barbe
et moustaches bien taillés maniant
l'épée avec brio dans des duels insensés
au service du roi de France
deux gars qui me ressemble un peu
finalement un peu bref les vrais
mousquetaires du roi correspondent-ils à
cette image véhiculée par la littérature
et le cinéma pour y répondre effectuons
un petit voyage dans le passé direction
le 19e siècle plus précisément le mois
de mars 1844 il y a tout pile 179 ans
cette année-là Alexandre Dumas qui est
déjà un auteur de théâtre bien connu
publie son nouveau roman Les Trois
mousquetaires l'histoire est simple mais
diablement efficace un jeune gascon
désargenté de 18 ans nommé d'Artagnan
débarque dans le pari du 17e siècle sous
le règne de Louis XII il veut intégrer
le corps des Mousquetaires un poste au
combien prestigieux un péteux et doté
d'un cœur gros comme ça il est solide
amitié avec trois d'entre eux Atos
portos et Aramis ensemble les quatre
compères vont voler d'aventure en
aventure pour sauver Louis XII la reine
et le royaume de France à de multiples
reprises les aventures des Trois
Mousquetaires deviennent en quelques
mois un véritable phénomène de société
des histoires d'amour compliquées du
mystère un contexte historique séduisant
du panache et l'élégance la recette est
imparable
Dumas pic électoral chaque semaine les
lecteurs du journal Le Siècle attendent
la suite de leur aventure un peu comme
on attend le Messie
en fait les Français découvrent les
trois mousquetaires dans la presse sous
la forme d'un roman feuilleton au 19e
siècle il est en effet très fréquent de
publier les romans d'aventure dans les
journaux en plusieurs épisodes le compte
de Monte-Cristo ou Arsène Lupin plus
tard seront également publiés dans la
presse en plusieurs épisodes avant
d'être disponible en librairie le roman
feuilleton c'est un peu l'ancêtre de nos
séries télé alors à l'époque les
mousquetaires d'Alexandre Dumas sont si
populaires que de nombreux lecteurs sont
persuadés qu'ils ont vraiment existé
alors à votre avis est-ce vrai ou faux
je vous donne la réponse un peu plus
tard intéressons-nous d'abord ou vrais
mousquetaires pas ceux du roman ils
appartiennent à une unité d'élite créée
par Louis XII en 1622 celui-ci décide de
détacher de la garde royale 50 cavaliers
triés sur le volet pour former une unité
indépendante on les appelle les
mousquetaires du roi et ce sont avant
tout des militaires formés pour le
combat mais il constitue aussi la garde
rapprochée du monarque ils escorte Louis
XII tous ces déplacements et assurent sa
sécurité 24 heures sur 24 c'est un peu
l'équivalent de notre GSPR le groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la
République bien évidemment ils sont
armés la particularité de ce corps c'est
que ces membres sont équipés d'une arme
révolutionnaire le mousquet un ancêtre
du fusil d'où le nom de ceux qui en sont
équipés les Mousquetaires le canon est
très long et larmes très lourde entre 3
et 5 kg avec une cadence de tir assez
faible parce qu'il faut recharger après
chaque tir insérer la poudre la balle
amorcée mousquet si encombrant qu'il est
impossible de tirer à cheval les soldats
doivent mettre pied à terre puis épauler
comme on le fait avec un fusil classique
c'est tellement peu pratique que sur le
champ de bataille les Mousquetaires
utilisent une fourquille une sorte de
piquet en forme de fourche qui sert de
support au canon malgré toutes ces
contraintes les mousquetaires excellent
dans son maniement il faut dire que les
armes c'est un peu leur dada ou
mousquetaires du roi ils sont beaucoup
plus hargneux et bagarreur que les
personnages du roman parce qu'ils ne
sont pas à la guerre ils passent
l'essentiel de leur temps à se battre en
duel mais pour ça évidemment il
n'utilise pas leur mosquée mais une épée
qu'on appelle la rapière au XVIIe siècle
c'est l'épée Rennes celle que tout le
monde utilise en Europe elle est légère
efficace et mortelle en France la
rapière connaît un grand succès mais un
succès un double tranchant les duels
entraînent de lourdes pertes chez les
jeunes nobles et les Mousquetaires
n'échappent bien entendu pas à la règle
ce qui ne tombe pas au combat périssant
duel et on dit d'ailleurs qu'un
mousquetaire qui atteint les 30 ans
c'est un mousquetaire chanceux ou bien
qui manque le courage mais peu importe
aux yeux du peuple ils incarnent l'image
d'hommes audacieux généreux et
indestructible qui n'ont peur de rien ni
de personne mousquetaire est à mi-chemin
entre la canaille magnifique et le noble
guerrier ah oui ben j'avais oublié de
vous le préciser les mousquetaires sont
des nobles c'est un critère de sélection
incontournable tu nous confirmes Jamy
absolument pour en être il faut être
bien né les candidats issus des grandes
familles aristocratiques ont plus de
chances d'être engagé que les membres de
la petite noblesse plus surprenants il
est préférable d'être originaire du
Béarn ou de Gascogne ce qui est le cas
de notre fameux d'Artagnan du coup ce
personnage est-il vraiment sorti de
l'imagination d'Alexandre Dumas et bien
non il a vraiment existé l'écrivain l'a
trouvé dans une biographie écrite par un
certain Gatien de Courtils de Cendras
elle relate la vie de Charles basse de
Castelmore un mousquetaire mort au
combat en 1673 l'auteur rapporte qu'il
est né à Loupiac dans le Gers autour de
1611 dans une famille noble très tôt se
battent de Castelmore nourrit une grande
ambition il veut devenir mousquetaire
mais on l'a dit pour avoir une chance
d'être recruté il faut être issu de la
grande noblesse ce qui n'est absolument
pas son cas les bases de castelmort ont
été que récemment à nobli donc quand il
est à l'âge de s'engager il décide de se
présenter sous un autre nom d'Artagnan
c'est pas vraiment un mensonge car il
est apparenté à cette grande famille par
sa mère et c'est bien joué cette
usurpation d'identité lui ouvre toutes
les portes en 1633 son rêve devient
réalité il est promu mousquetaire
ça me va bien donnez-moi votre avis en
commentaire
d'Artagnan va servir Louis XII jusqu'à
la mort du roi en 1643 et mousquetaires
sont dissous en 1646 d'Artagnan entre un
peu après au service de la région bande
d'Autriche elle dirige le royaume d'une
main de maître et du redoutable cardinal
Mazar alors côté il traverse une période
trouble la fraude les affrontements
éclatent un peu partout dans Paris parmi
les conjurés il y a des gens du peuple
de la bourgeoisie mais aussi une partie
de la noblesse qui rêve de renverser la
couronne d'Artagnan ne bronze pas il
reste fidèle à Anne d'Autriche ce
dévouement lui vaut la confiance du
jeune Louis XIV et lui permet de
relancer sa carrière militaire du coup
lorsque la compagnie des Mousquetaires
est reconstituée en 1657
il en prend tout naturellement la tête
à ce titre d'Artagnan est même chargé
d'escorter le souverain à
Saint-Jean-de-Luz en 1660 pour son
mariage avec l'infante en 1161 c'est
aussi à lui que l'on confie
l'arrestation de Nicolas Fouquet
puissant ministre des Finances de Louis
XIV qui est accusé d'avoir détourné
l'argent du royaume il assure sa
surveillance en prison pendant trois ans
enfin honneur suprême il est nommé
gouverneur de l'île en décembre 1672
cette grande cité tient un rôle
stratégique majeur pour la France mais
c'est en militaire que notre
mousquetaire finit sa vie en 1673 coût
du destin il est tué sur le champ de
bataille abattu par une balle de mosquée
voilà pour le personnage historique
est-ce qu'on en sait cette biographie
est probablement un peu romancée mais
elle regorge d’aote et de personnages
qu'Alexandre Dumas utilise pour parfaire
ses histoires c'est à dire dans ce livre
qu'on y trouve aussi le nom de deux de
ses mousquetaires Henri daramitz qu'il
transforme en Aramis et Isaac de Porto
qui devient portos en revanche Thibault
la fameuse devise des Mousquetaires un
pour tous tous pour un et bien c'est
totalement fake elle n'a jamais servi de
devises aux mousquetaires du roi c'est
en réalité la traduction en français
d'une vieille locution latine qui sert
aujourd'hui de devise non-officielle de
la Suisse et on s'en fiche que ce soit
faux puisque c'est un roman et que dans
un roman on a le droit de tout inventer
plus incroyable encore un pour tous pour
un est en réalité une citation
erronée elle n'apparaît jamais sous
cette forme dans le roman mais sous la
forme inversée pousse pour un pour tous
mes au fait les vrais mousquetaires que
sont-ils devenus après la mort de Louis
XIV ils ont traversé son règne sans
encombre mais les deux compagnies de
mousquetaires parce qu'il y en avait
deux ça coûte très cher à entretenir et
à partir du XVIIIe siècle on fait de
moins en moins appel à elle si bien
qu'en 1775 les Mousquetaires sont
purement et simplement supprimés pour
faire des économies des années plus tard
en 1814 Louis XVII tente de rétablir les
Mousquetaires histoire de restaurer le
la période napoléonienne mais ça ne va
pas durer longtemps au bout d'un peine
un an ils sont de nouveau priés de
rentrer chez eux toujours par mesure
d'économie en tout cas les mousquetaires
du roi doivent une fière chandelle à
Alexandre Dumas c'est grâce à lui que
c'est valeux militaires n'ont pas sombré
dans les oubliettes de l'histoire
aujourd'hui les Mousquetaires sont
partout au cinéma bien sûr au théâtre à
l'opéra dans les bandes dessinées
savez-vous qu'il existe aussi une série
de marionnettes japonaises les trois
mousquetaires une série coréenne un film
égyptien un autre mexicain un Russe des
parodies un balai australien la liste
est longue plus proche de nous la France
a décidé de se doter d'une équipe
nationale de football américain pour la
Ligue européenne mais connais-tu son nom
les mousquetaires de Paris bien entendu
merci Thibault je suis sûr que dans une
autre vie tu as été un grand
mousquetaire comme d'Artagnan si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
mettre un pouce bleu et à vous abonner
et surtout indiquez-nous en commentaire
les sujets d'histoire que vous aimez on
regardera ça très près avec Thibault à
très bientôt chers épicurieuses et pic
curieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]